thank you so much for the nice
introduction it's a pleasure to be here
I was actually a postdoc here a long
time ago from 2003 to 2006 it's nice to
come back and give a talk today um so
I'll talk today about image domain
transfer which I'll introduce in a
minute so I'm part of Nvidia research
immediate research is collection of
researchers in blue work on a number of
things really all the way from sort of
circuits it's a very low level of harbor
all the way up to you know machine
learning and computer vision our mission
is to develop technology through through
research we have about 140 researcher in
11 different time zones and then my team
to learning perception team is about 20
people and our focus really is a lot of
computer vision research and today I'll
talk about some of it and I called it
image domain transfer and the tasks I'm
looking at it's yeah one way to think
about it is can we teach machines some
form of imagination abilities and then
yeah we'll see it's not really
imagination it's just yeah learning by
example but still can we do things like
this can we have an input image and ask
a computer to translate into what it
might look like say on a rainy day
alright so given a sunny day image can
we teach it to take this image and
translate it to look like as if we were
taken during a rainy day and you know we
just need to play some function apply
some function effort that takes this
image and transfers it yeah to a rainy
day the question is how can we do this
and I'll talk about a whole series of
techniques that refused to do things
along those lines
now you want to ask why would I want to
do this in the first place right
so the example I showed this is actually
one I'll come back to but it's other
examples of translating one image to
another with the goal of enhancing it or
changing in some particular way so it
could go blow race to high-res for
instance or if a verb Lurie image am I
going to make it sharp or if you have a
photograph you might want to make it
look like a painting or if you have a
loader
too much you might want to make it look
like Hina my grant image or if you're a
synthetic image you might make it look
more real or if you're a thermal image
maybe you want to add color tread and
then sort the other examples that I just
showed if you had some are a summer
image maybe want to make it a rainy day
in which or winter image if you have a
data image can I make it a night time in
which and so forth there's lots of
application of Nia translating one image
to a different domain that's related but
somewhat different and yeah being in
video the ones we're actually quite
interested in it's actually the last one
to represent so day to night yeah data
or summer to winter summer to rainy day
and the reason is if you can do you know
this type of translation you might not
need to acquire as much training data
for a particular use case say you want
to train yeah something for yourself
driving car right and you've taken lots
of footage in California which is yeah
always funny all right
so no I'm gonna try and train it maybe
or test it on winter image so either I
go out and capture more data or maybe I
can take my existing data and make it
look like a severe winter or at night or
rainy and so forth so I'll talk about
two main approaches and they'll spend
most of the time over on the second part
or the second approach so one approach
is you take examples and then based on
this example you derive how an image
should be translated to another image
and this is usually called not
nonparametric so it we don't actually
train anything really just base it on an
example and take this example and
somehow apply it to our image so the
function is the translating function f
takes an example in it and uses this to
the translation and then I'll spend a
lot of time under learning based methods
where we have some training set and we
learn this function f to go say from
summer to winter so how this first one
work well
it's often French for is often referred
to style transference actually lots of
old methods to do this especially in
graphics originally but now also in the
computer vision community is quite a few
methods do this and the set up is
usually false you have some kind of
content photo right it's usually a
photograph you want to take it
and modified to look like a given style
photo so I can give you a style and the
content folder and now you want to apply
this style to the content and make it
look like yeah like this right it's
still the same pyramid or glass pyramid
and now it has a style of architecture
photograph on the left so in a way it's
it's quite simple right we generated an
output given the input and given the
example which is the style photo and
that's it now the question is how do we
do it there is a lot of work on artistic
style transfer and you might have seen
some of this where the goal is to take a
content and make it look like a painting
all right so here we apply this starry
night and get you know output of I think
it's tubing in and now looks like you
know the painting what we want to look
at today is what we call photo style
France where the input is a photo the
style is also photo I'm gonna apply at
this photographic style to our content
image and there's a slight difference
between the two in the artistic style
transfer your K or actually you desire
to change some of the geometry in the
scene right so it's fine if the houses
all of a sudden get bent a little bit
right that's that's part of the style
whereas for photographic in which is
that's not the case you want to leave
the geometry alone you just want to have
the look to be different and the work
we've done recently published is EC CV
and it's this two-step process
so we first so we model this photograph
excel transfer it's a closed form
function and we applied to function so
it's function f1 function f to the first
function applies to style photograph and
and that that's a yeah neural network
based and it does okay but it leaves
some artifacts and then B applies of a
second function which we call so the
first one we call sterilization ship and
the second one we call a smoothing step
to get rid of some of their sort of
wobbly artifacts that you can see it's
all of this work it's similar to degree
to the neural style transfer work that
you might have seen so the main insight
is or the main assumption that we make
and it turns out to be true is that if
you encode your
on the left side the input image and you
have an an encoder and encodes it into
some space and we just used vgg 19 so we
use an existing vgg Network we encode it
up to a fourth layer and take the
features that come out of it we make
this assumption that the covariance
matrix of those features actually encode
this style somehow so if you take the
covariance matrix now HC is the are the
features of the content image HC x HC
transpose Y is the covariance matrix and
we make the assumption that those
somehow encode the style features so we
can take the features from both the
content image as well as the style image
and now we're trying to enforce the
covariance the covariances of the style
features onto the content features so
that they look alike and it's actually
fairly simple to do so we encode the
image didn't be applied it's whitening
step it's really like yeah normal
whitening step let me apply a coloring
step which really take just make sure
that yeah those covariances are the same
and then we decode it again so it's a
it's almost like a normal encoder
decoder architecture except for this
whitening coloring step and outcomes
style transfer image and this is similar
to previous work we also make use of
labels if they're available a previous
work also uses this so if we know the
sky you know this part of an image is
described in this part of this tile and
which is also sky we mapped those
together to make sure if we don't mix
near roads and skies and so forth well
you get this this so style on the left
content in the middle so we applied the
style on the content and we get yeah the
output on the right I think as you can
see for the top image it looks it looks
alright for the bottom image it does
apply to style of divs this image to
this content photo however you can see
in the clouds yeah they're sort of these
artifacts are it's a little wobbly its
overall yes the style is there but the
geometry has suffered a bit but it's
more wobbly than it should be so we
apply the second step which we call
photo smoothing and it's actually a
fairly simple idea what we say is that
the
omit that the pixel in the resulting
image neighboring pixels their
relationships should be similar to the
original image of the style sorry of the
content they shouldn't change all that
much right
it's ok to apply the style but the the
relationship between neighboring pixels
should still remain the same and we just
imposed this through an optimization
which actually has a closed form
solution to really make make sure that
the similarity between neighboring
pixels is the same between the image
that we are creating and the original
one and one to apply this you get much
better results so this is the original
output again and once we apply this
smoothing step you get this so all the
while the artifacts yeah you can see
that disappear and it's much more
similar to the original content photo
but it has to style from the style that
are applied so let me show you a few
more examples and comparisons so again
content and style and we applied our sis
on the right and then in the middle is
two previous methods one is actually 46
I'll transfer and one is for
photographic style transfer and they
work yeah okay but you can see for
instance this one that was geared
towards East I'll transfer it often
create some artifacts right so the
geometry of the pyramid it's not quite
the same anymore
whereas for ours it remains the same we
show few more examples so again you know
style applied to the content photo and
this is compared to some older method
and just one it's from last year I think
or prove it here and this is our result
and overall yeah ours works fairly
consistently the style is usually
applied fairly well and there's hardly
any artifacts or you can see a little
bit here that it looks a little yeah
maybe not quite right but it's overall
it's very good we did a user study to
see what people thought about different
methods that I just showed and we asked
two question to compare how well
photograph a stylized so how well do we
replicate the stylized photo and how
well and how photo realistic is theirs
image so basically how little artifacts
are there and you know overall um ours
was preferred in addition Dartmouth is
actually fairly fast it's very efficient
it's just really an encoder decoder
which is fast to do what so this the
first part I wanted to show this sort of
more classical method in a sense that
it's based on an example and you apply
it to an image so it's similar to older
methods except that you use a neural
network in the middle to do some other
work whereas all the work that I'm going
to show from now on it's all based on
training on a training set and learning
this function and this function is
represented as a neural network of some
kind and in particular all the work that
I'm going to show for non it's all based
on on generative adversarial neural
networks you've probably seen ganz at
some point in your course that I'll go
over it very very briefly so again it's
the following so there's two components
to again so you have a generator which
takes some vector Z it's a latent vector
Z and based on this vector it generates
an output image and at the beginning
it's just a neural network randomized
with random sorry initialized with
random weights and it'll output some
random image all right
then there's a discriminator which will
check whether your output is realistic
or not and the question is what does
realistic mean well actually what it
means is the discriminator is supposed
to check whether the synthesized image
is similar or the distribution of the
synthesized images is similar to the
distribution of your training data set
so you might have a training data set of
say faces as in this example here then
your goal the goal for the generator is
to generate images of faces that are
similar to the one in a training set and
has and with a similar distribution so
that's its goal the discriminators goal
is to figure out whether the generator
synthesizes images that are similar to
those in the training set or if they're
different so for instance if you were
generator accident they were to
synthesize a car it would say no this is
yeah it's not a face well it's not a
realistic face or if you were to
generate by accident a cartoon
it should also say no it's not a
realistic face because it doesn't look
like my training set of realistic faces
and he trained these two in a ping-pong
fashion so both are neural networks but
both are generator and the discriminated
and neural networks and they're both
trained together really well one of the
other usually near ping pong fashion and
surprisingly you can actually make this
work right even though yeah needle
generator or the discriminator actually
knows anything at the beginning they
still manage to converge to a reasonable
solution and synthesize realistic images
most of the Gantt work works in a
supervised fashion meaning you have
training samples at Roy training Paris
right you have an input image say a shoe
given oh sorry
notice you give it an image given edges
and the output might be a
realistic-looking
shoes right it might be a training pair
so you know that you should go from this
edge image to this particular shoe we'll
also talk a bit about the unsupervised
setting where I have two training sets
but they're not in correspondence it
might be one training set of data images
they might one and the other training
set might be nighttime images they might
all be driving videos all right so they
might they're related to training sets
but they're not identical in a sense
that for x1 I have a corresponding image
x2 that was taken at night type from the
same point of view with the same cars in
the same place right because it's
difficult do actually it's impossible to
do to create data sets that are in full
correspondence if you want to go from
daytime to nighttime our boosters always
something that moves then you're
unsupervised fashion I have just two
separate training sets they're similar
but not in direct correspondence in
addition we also care about unimodal
verses multimodal so what I just showed
where the original candidates explained
there was a unimodal model meaning if
you want to do translations say from
dogs two cats it might only output one
cat right where's the multimodal model
you might be able to give it serve
another style vector and you might be
able to go not just from one dog to one
cat but to potentially different cats
that have yea different looks
so these are all the different ways of
classifying the work that I'm going to
present today and there's lots of work
in this space and this is just a list of
some of the gann papers that came out
with the last year or two and I'll talk
about some homework and I'll put that in
context so first one I'd like to talk
about fixed to pics HD which we
presented this year sorry last year at
cvpr and it's supervised and it's
multimodal and and really the goal was
here to do a conditional again that goes
from a label map which he shot which I
showed at the very beginning to an image
so given labels of the scene so the
labels say yeah this is road this is
sidewalk this is car this is you know
people and so forth given these labels I
want to synthesize an image that looks
realistic but corresponds to the label
that I'm given all right so now I need
to learn this somehow how do I learn
this we will make use of Gans with a
slight difference to the way I explained
to him at the beginning so now the input
is not just a latent vector z but rather
it's the label map if it's an image so
we want to condition the generator on
the label image this the discriminator
still does the same thing it still will
tell you or it's it's task is to tell
you whether the synthesized image looks
like a real ya image except it also
knows what the labels look like so it
can sort of check whether or you can try
and figure out whether to synthesize the
image actually corresponds to the labels
and whether it's you know similar to
other images in the training set right
so in that sense it's similar in
addition what we do we add sources
multi-modality
to it so we add to this additional step
so once we finish training um we look at
all the features underneath a particular
label so if we look at all the streets
we look at all the cars and so forth and
then we try and cluster the features
that we see during training so for
instance for the road you might have
seen a lot of standard tar right
substandard yeah
Rhodes but you might also have seen
cobblestone and to hope is by clustering
you can figure out today sort of two
dominant things which is normal Road
which is paved and cobblestone road
because once we do this we can actually
use this for the synthesis we can give
it to the decoder and say it should be
one or the other so you can actually do
a multi-modal synthesis then there's
some other tricks that we play to make
sure it actually works well and those
are really important so if you just use
the standard again the quality of
results is usually okay but not great so
we do two things we do we change the
generator and train it in a coarse to
fine fashion so we first train it to
synthesize low res images and then once
we're good at these low resolution
images we take it and add sort of layers
around it serve it at the beginning at
the end to make it synthesize higher
resolution images and that really helps
a lot furthermore we have these multi
scale discriminator so we discriminate
so discriminate or not just looks at the
high resolution images but images of
different resolutions which helps it to
server have a better global view of
what's going on so it's better
discriminating badly synthesized images
from from what they actually should look
like and we also use this robust
objective so instead of just doing the
Gantt loss we we also add what people
call a feature loss so feature losses
are often used when you're when your
task is to synthesize or create images
of some kind which means that you don't
just look whether your synthesized image
looks like a particular other image so
you don't just use an L to different say
an l1 norm between images but rather e
to it in the space of a neural network
so in this case if we take the features
of the discriminator and check what it
is similar between our you know training
images and there are synthesized images
which also helps a lot sometimes it's
also called a vgg loss and it's quite
useful
what so when you do all those things you
can do something like this so here ya
label map is shown on the top and then
we go through different modalities so
it's always the same
a structure that we create except we say
go through different pavements and
different cobblestone and change the
cars go through different potential cars
you know always it does something
sensible if you look carefully you can
see it it's not always great like the
white car you know it doesn't look
perfect actually if it comes up again it
looks ya slightly funky but overall it's
actually surprising that you can learn
you know from just the data set off
label maps and their corresponding
images you can actually learn to
synthesize realistic looking or mostly
realistic looking images if you're gonna
now change some of the labels in the
background so some of this guy we make
too so here the sky becomes trees you
know we change the trees to buildings
and so you can actually change this on
the fly not on the fly you can actually
change this and resynthesize and you get
a reasonable image out it's really quite
neat to do this you can also if you'd
like yes or paint parts that you want to
be houses or paint parts that you want
to be a tree so you can do modifications
of your label map and then at the neural
network just synthesize this and an
image according to your label map so
it's sort of painting by numbers and it
works yeah fairly well it's a comparison
to some of the previous work it's only
top left its previous method that was
called picks two picks and then CRN
which are more classical method in the
top right then ours at the bottom to our
ours both with the feature Lawson
without the feature loss and it's hard
to tell but the one on the right is
slightly better than the one on the left
so this was picks two picks then more
recently we extended this to videos so
it was published at nurbs late last year
so now the difference is that we don't
want to just take a single frame as
input and synthesize an image but rather
a video of label maps and synthesize a
video of realistic looking scenes
according to the video of label maps now
you could say well why don't just use
you know what you just presented right
depicts your picks HD and apply it in
our per frame basis
and you can do this except it looks like
this each frame is alright
except temporally they're not coherent
because we didn't ask you to be
temporally coherent it doesn't know
anything about previous images for next
image this that follow so each image is
okay but overall yeah it flickers a lot
right so it's not quite what you want so
we need to do something to make it too
poorly coherent and it's it's fairly
clear sorry Tara and it's a really an
extension of pics to excite she says
it's very similar in architecture so the
first thing we do we built a sequential
generator so now we say you don't just
get a single map as input but what you
get you know multiple frames of label
Maps as input you also get past images
to be synthesized to actually know what
what's happened before
based on these we created an
intermediate output in addition we also
compute optical flow between the
previous images so we know how things
have been moving we use the flow to warp
to warp the previous image into what the
next image could look like and then we
combine our synthesized image with the
protein with the warped image what it
might look like into a final image and
that helps I'm be obvious in network -
yeah - combine this then the trick of
using multiple scales for the
discriminator we use the same thing
again we do it not just spatially but
also temporally so when we discriminate
things we look at different spatial
resolutions but also different temporal
time frames we look at larger distances
as well as smaller distances the
training we still do progressive but we
don't just do it low resolution first
and high resolution but we do it low
resolution to high resolution as well as
temporally we do it sort of smaller
frames smaller temporal time steps and
then larger ones so we do it special
temporally progressive and then we
alternate between space and time when we
train so if you combine all this you can
now take this video
sorry went too far
take this video and turn it into a real
video in a second there you go
so you can see now it's temporally
consistent it is still not perfect if
you look carefully yeah you can see some
things are a little funky - trees seem a
little repetitive
the cars are glowing a little bit but
overall yeah it does let me play again
well it does a decent job when this is
on running on unseen label map so it
hasn't seen this particular sequence of
label maps of course right in this
corner
compared against to the previous method
the pics of pics HD on the top right
previous method bottom left that one was
also not meant for temporal sequences so
it also flickers and ours on the right
it does exit the autor surprisingly
decent job at synthesizing people
okay
now we can do the same thing for edges
so in this case we trained it on edges
and with yourself people since we have
to style or this is this multi-modality
where we look at you know what things
usually look like on average so yeah the
clustering figured out that's different
skin tones missed different hair colors
so now we can change skin tone and hair
color so input is just the edges on the
bottom left and we synthesize three
different well the same person three
times but with different hair and skin
tone
and here we've taken wages of someone
dancing so those examples of her dancing
and then yeah we extracted the pose and
then from this post we animated this
little colored figure and now we can
take new poses and since and go from the
colored figures figure to her dancing
again and you can see yeah if again you
look careful if you look careful it
works well ish
there's some places where yeah some
poses maybe it's not seen during
training so it doesn't quite know how to
do right the background wobbles
sometimes a little bit
but you know it's it's a start
also you notice that we use this colored
figure a previous label maps to are all
just uniformly colored right it just
said yeah this is the label for trees
this is the label for cars and so forth
here we did it slightly differently net
improved results so we have these
different colors and they're basically
UV coordinates like on the texture map
or like if you texture a person and it
helps to neural network to know what's
where alright so you can figure out what
what hands are it always knows which
part of the hand you're looking at and
it's same thing for all other body parts
so that helps quite a bit this the first
time we combine machine learning and
computer graph is to do I can't turn off
so this one was a NURBS so this is
actually running in real time so we take
as input a game engine that only outputs
label maps and then we take these label
maps and in real time we translate them
using they're not neural network and we
apply different styles and this is just
one example just a short example that I
found so it's really doing graphics
using yeah neural network so all the
textures and so forth everything comes
from the neural network it only sees
label maps that our game engine spits
out so the game engine is actually not
used to produce graphics it's only used
to produce label apps and you can take
it and produce like a game looking or
something like a game right okay so this
was all supervised learning so in this
case we always had yeah input examples
and what the output examples should look
like so we knew it for this particular
label map this particular output would
be desirable then this work it's just a
bit older we didn't use this we used we
tried to work with it in the
unsupervised case we're really we have
these two different data sets yeah like
the one on the Left no one on the right
that are separate it's not no one-to-one
correspondence between them they're just
happened to be similar except one is a
daytime and one is it
so now how can we yeah given that
there's no correspondents right how can
we train a neural network to take a
summer on in which taking it turn the
day and output an image during the night
that corresponds to it but it's at
nighttime right so if we let's say for a
moment all we do is we train again again
and we tell it here my input images
right based on this input image you have
to synthesize an output image it looks
similar to these other nighttime images
and it's all we tell it then what might
happen is the following
yeah I'm gonna yeah the generator it's
gonna generate things given the input
image x1 but there that are similar to
the distribution of the nighttime images
however it doesn't mean that there will
be a correspondence between the
synthesized night time image and the
input image right I didn't tell it that
they need to look alike all I said is
they need the night time in which images
need to look like nighttime images but
it didn't say it needs to look like a
nighttime image but also like the
original image right so what would
happen is given the state time in which
it'll just never would probably just
ignore this daytime image because it
doesn't really need it to produce a
nighttime in which it's just gonna
produce random nighttime images which is
not what we want but what we want is the
chute being correspondents so we make
this assumption what you call the shared
latent space so again I want to create
an item which is actually responds to
the HMI which was just the case here
even though I've never seen different
correspondents so it makes the
assumption that there's some space in
which I can describe the scene I'm
currently in right so have if I take a
point in this latent space Z I can
somehow generate a daytime image as well
as a nighttime image and this light in
space is sufficient to describe either
one of them but what I have then is you
know different encoders ting can go from
a daytime image and encode it into this
latent space and they have different
generators that can take a code from
latent space and generate either daytime
or nighttime image so yeah if we want to
translate it then I can just use my echo
to encode from a daytime to the late in
space and I can use my generator to to
encode a night time of it but in
addition what we do is to fall we make
for these different encoders and
generators even though they're different
ones we share weights near the latent
space so the generator itself yeah
generate something then encodes it too
late in space and they the generator
takes it from the latent space and
encodes that sorry and creates an image
from it and the layers that are near
delayed in space we make them the same
for all encoders and generators and that
in itself is sufficient to make sure
that there is some similarity between
the input and the output so now what I
can do is after shared space I can go
between two different encoders and the
way you train it there's there's one
additional constraint that you know off
and that is if i encode an image and
they're decoded so I take a nighttime
image i encoded with my encoder and then
it decoded again with my nighttime
encoder it should correspond to the
original image right all I did is so
went to the late in space I'm going back
to the same domain I should be able to
it
yeah encoded correctly and the same
thing for the daytime image and those
constraints itself there sufficient to
make this work so now here is input and
output again trained in an unsupervised
fashion but it still manages to figure
out that cars during a day usually at
night they have the taillights on
disguise black they're rodas or
illuminated near myself but in further
way might not because my headlights
might not go far enough
it also learns that sometimes you can
see here that some of them says lights
yeah somewhere so it's almost just adds
lights randomly in the sky it's learned
that that's common
I also learned that the cars usually all
look black or dark at night whereas the
taillights might be red or white so this
is going day tonight I can do the same
thing for winter to summer so in this
case here we have training for driving
videos of during the winter driving
videos in the summer and it learns to go
yeah really from winter to summer and it
learns this on its own and I'll show you
some funky thinks that it's learned so
you'll you'll see what it learns that
vertical structures are usually trees
right but it doesn't really know that
it's a difference between these
electricity posts and trees so sometimes
it puts leaves on those because it looks
a bit like a tree right so it thinks
well yeah the other things have leaves
so maybe they should have leaves as well
which is not a bad yeah not a bad thing
to think here again you can see put
leaves on them but it also learns that
where there's snow in the winter right
yeah I should remove it so you know
usually puts some dirt color there or
some you know some grass color which is
quite interesting so it derives all this
on its own right nobody told it that you
know these are trees and and snow
disappears and it's armored it learned
that this is what usually happens and
this series goes from sunny to rainy
again it's learned that the sky is
usually more grave and it rains yeah
usually and usually there's reflections
on the road so it makes all roads
slightly reflective I also learned that
things are slightly more hazy when it's
raining so I did that
it also learned that which is actually
interesting that near taillights there's
often a red halo around them because of
the mist all right so you can see makes
this brighter but then it doesn't really
know to distinguish red car from tail
light so there's a red car and now
become sir has just it's like glow
around it because it also things it's
like a tail light
again overall given that it's only seen
two separate data sets that are not in
correspondence it's managed to figure
out now that the road should be more you
know more shiny or more reflective this
guy should be more great and all of this
was done overnight automatically right
nobody told it that that's what it's
going to be so this was a unimodal
translation so you could only create one
output all right not multiple different
outputs then we have an extension of
this work which again is unsupervised
but it allows to output things in a
multi-modal fashion so you can change
the style of the output and it works
very similar to before again we have an
encoder that goes into some shared
latent space but in and then you can
come from this Leighton space and
generate an out but in addition though
we have two styl encoders where we
automatically try and learn what the
style looks like of something that's
being coded and when it decoded I can
give it a style and the decoder should
adhere to the style a given so it could
be things like yeah I'm translating st.
leopards or Lions whatever it is to cats
I can have different styles during the
generation part and the different styles
correspond yeah to different cats but
they're all cats in the same pose just
yeah the different they're looking
different but it's overall it's very
similar to you know except yeah all this
the same except there's this additional
styling coder that we use and we play
the same trick that we played before
that you know if i encode something with
the style and decode with this file with
the same style it should look the same
and again that sort of sufficient to
make this all work
the structure is very similar to before
except now we used two bit more advanced
network with residual blocks you know a
content encoder which we didn't do
before for the style encoder we used
this trick which is called ADA and which
is adaptive instance arm realization
it's really where for each layer I
enforce a particular mean and standard
deviation essentially and that's yeah
sufficient
to change the style and it's been
showing its work in a number of use
cases so what can I do with this so in
this case we've create a synthetic say
that data said so we actually know what
to course what ground truth is even
though we learned it without
correspondences we actually have
correspondences so we have inputs of
images of shoes but only their edges and
we also have the apparent truth images
for them even though we trained it in an
unsupervised fashion and now I can ask
it they're never given this image of
shoes I saw edges give me example shoes
and I'll go through different styles and
it's gonna give me shoes that all adhere
to the edges but of different colors
right and they're sensible
so it's learn the sensible styles of
shoes yes it's yes it's not it's not
entirely obvious so for if you ignore
the style for a moment it really is this
really only one two constraints one is
that if i encode myself right and
decoded myself against with the same
with a corresponding encoded decoder or
encoder generator then you have a day
time in which i want the same day time
image back right that's your work and if
ever nighttime image i should get the
same night time of inch back so that's
the main constraint in addition when you
think the other sort of encoder for
daytime encoder for night time which is
generator for daytime which generator
for nighttime and which is these all
neural networks but each one is a neural
network the neural networks they share
weights near the latent space so it's
the same identical weights so the
encoders need to serve the beginning of
the encoders they do something that's
domain-specific to daytime or nighttime
but then once they're sort of near the
latent space they have the same weights
so there's some kind of will force them
to be in a space that's similar so at
that point it's independent if it's
daytime or nighttime in the same
for the generator at that point at the
beginning when they start generating
things it's the same way it's either
independent of daytime or nighttime and
then we have sort of the specific
weights to daytime and tonight them
which is the the reason why they're in
correspondence and that's really the
main reason the Train yeah but we train
them we just make sure yeah we've forced
him to be the same during training
actually the main the main inside and
yet the same the same here again except
with the addition of two style encoder
right what so no yeah I can create all
kind of shoes I can do it same thing for
bags and it learns the interesting
styles right so you can translate yeah
this image of edges of a back into the
various different bags and now we can do
the same thing that we did before so
let's up at the bottom one we can go
from summer to winter or winter to
summer except now because it's seen lots
of examples already seen some examples
where it's more snow and less snow some
examples where there might be more Leafs
and less leaves it actually learned to
use these different styles so now I can
go from winter to summer but also maybe
to a bit more spring where this you know
fewer Leafs and they can go from summer
to winter but with more or less know
what it's learned that the mapping then
we also did from cityscapes which just
realistic private leaders to this
synthetic images of driving and it's
learned that there's things like I think
this is rain there's snow and there's
near dusk and the same thing here we go
from a synthetic to realistic images of
silly scenes and it's learn today's surf
cobblestone again and different
pavements and for different looks and we
can do the same thing for ya
applying surf photographic style in a
way so here we've given it lots of
images of summer and winter images of
you know your somebody but some of them
were taking at night some of them we're
taking at dawn some of them are taking
yeah yeah when it was nice out some
so I'm wearin so it learns different
styles so when you go from summer to
winter yes they all have some a little
bit of snow but some of them are you
know during a bright day some of them
are sunset and so forth the same when
you go from winter to summer somewhere
taking at night some we're taking during
the day and it's learned today Steve
different styles now the different
styles they're not disentangle meaning I
can't tell you it should be sort of
nighttime and more snow or because it
doesn't know about this so it's surf
one style which encodes all of the
different aspects of the image and you
can't actually just angle it there's the
other work who could apply but in this
case we didn't actually disentangle it
so now this is an example where we
translate from a dog video to a cat
video but since we have a style code we
can go through different types of cats
and then we can animate the dog again
and all its scene is really videos of or
images of dogs and images of cats and
it's learned how to translate them and
here we go house cat - big cat but we
interpolate in the latent space sorry we
interpolate the style code so it's the
same cat do you always see or the same
pose I should say but different types of
cats yeah go from cat dog I get it's
always the same pose but different
styles
it's interesting was actually even
learned that yeah some animals or some
styles have you know our furrier so
they're bigger and so it actually yeah
gross them a little bit to accommodate
the fur shrinks them again which is
which is quite interesting of course
once we have this we can also do it you
know what's called style transfer
meaning I want to apply a particular
style given an example image so similar
to the very first part of the talk so
here I have a tease potential shoes I
want to synthesize give them their edges
and now I can tell you I want this style
or this style or this style and then
kind of apply it to all kinds of
different shoes right so can have the
same style applied to different shoes
and the same thing can be done therefore
here we going from big cats to house
cats and they can tell you I want this
particular type of cat but in the pose
of the big cat that's on the left and
again this is an unsupervised fashion
but it learned what the correspondent
should be it learned that these poses
are similar without being told
explicitly right there's a comparison
between different methods in all
fairness not all of them are actually
geared towards this particular use case
so yeah ours worked fairly well which is
not surprising we made it
yeah such that it would work well in
this case where some of the sort of more
traditional neural our style transferred
they're not quite meant for it this is
actually the first work that I showed
yeah it's not really meant for this case
it doesn't work as well because these
are meant for sort of just applying
style but not changing yet a particular
animal as we did in this case in this
case right okay so this concludes my
talk so I've presented a lot of methods
on translating one image to another
omits another image in various ways
supervised Unser Royce you know model
and multi modal and that's it
thank you
[Applause]